Burning Man the annual week-long
festival held at the end of summer in
the Nevada desert is facing a terrifying
challenge that goes to the very heart of
its ethos of radical self-expression
anti-tax activist Grover Norquist
has announced he will be attending this
year's Burning Man and a voluntary
community dedicated to radical inclusion
survive the presence of a man with
Norquist terrifying ideology including
his backward political views on marriage
equality I'm not sure the state really
should be involved in making those
decisions okay but you are a war monger
we need to think through whether every
war is a good idea or whether sometimes
not jumping out into traffic is a
smarter move but you do hate immigrants
right
look this country was built with
immigrants this is all about people
voluntarily deciding to come here
because it's a free and open society
when people don't want to come that's
the time to worry fine at least we can
all agree that you hate pot legalization
I think the 50 states or 57 states can
make these decisions themselves they're
taking different approaches we'll see
what works please tell me you're a crony
capitalist I'm not in favor of the
government stealing anybody's money and
giving it to anyone else whether it's
giving it to somebody who won't work or
giving it to a company that won't make a
product other people wish to buy damn
right fine whatever I still don't see
why you want to go hang out with a bunch
of hippies playing with fire in the
middle of the desert I'm going to
Burning Man because it's a bunch of
people voluntarily getting together to
do fun and interesting things and nobody
tells anybody else what to do and it's
the way the world should work it's
exactly where every free-market
freethinker ought to be at least once in
their life
all right I'll see you there